cloud technology is rapidly advancing
and changing the way we do business
nearly 90
of companies rely on cloud computing and
spending on cloud services is estimated
to have hit 97 billion
last year as companies continue
investing in cloud migration
hybrid cloud has emerged as the secure
flexible solution
that many large and mid-size companies
are choosing
as a result the demand for engineers who
can build and maintain
hybrid solutions is growing rapidly
that's why udacity has teamed up with
nutanix
the industry leader in hybrid cloud
infrastructure to build the hybrid cloud
engineer nanodegree program with the
guidance of expert instructors from
nutanix
you'll learn how to navigate the nutanix
hyper-converged infrastructure platform
design a hybrid application deployment
and translate
infrastructure requirements into a calm
blueprint
these skills will equip you with the
tools you need to successfully complete
real-world projects throughout this
program as you design a hybrid cloud
solution
create a hybrid cloud application
architecture and
launch a marketplace blueprint prepare
yourself for the future of cloud
technology
enroll today in the hybrid cloud
engineer nanodegree program
and be in demand